bonsoir il est 18 heures en ce 9 avril
merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'actu voici les
principaux titres nous en parlions hier
en plateau avec le professeur dalne
agence de biomédecine entend faire
progresser le nombre de donneurs
potentiels de moelle osseuse des
témoignages de receveurs donc cette
édition sébastien proyart revient sur la
création de son association médias
handicape depuis montigny le bretonneux
une association pour changer le regard
sur les personnes en situation de
handicap il est l'invité de ce journal
et puis chaque année la ville de
versailles consacre son exposition sur
la bande dessinée à de grandes
signatures découvrait actuellement un
hommage aux collections de l'éditeur le
lombard une image pour débuter c'est à
saint germain en laye mardi matin trois
mille girafe en plastique ont envahi la
place à charles de gaulle devant le
château de saint germain l'indémodable
sophie la girafe symbole du nouveau
concept de communication de parly 2 au
chesnay les passants étaient invités à
rapporter ces girafes à l'accueil du
centre afin de découvrir des surprises
inattendues un expected en anglais c'est
le nom de cette campagne imaginée par l'
agence btc shopper et développé par
unibail rodamco des affiches vous l'avez
vu un aussi et est décliné sur cet
événement avec d'autres objets
emblématiques des différentes
générations
à noter que la guerre des centres
commerciaux se poursuit l'espace 50 ans
à montigny le bretonneux inaugure de son
côté aujourd'hui ses nouveaux
aménagements le propriétaire le groupe
hammerson investi quelques 7 millions et
demi d'euros éclairage carrelage
tablettes tactiles prochaine étape
l'intégration de l'espace kayes ouest au
centre historique nouvelle liaison
pédestre nouvelles offres pour les
clients le projet de refonte de skywest
en magasin de déstockage de luxe a été
abandonnée vous le savez l'année
dernière
trouver un boulot pour l'été lorsque
l'on est étudiant un moment toujours
angoissant mais pour simplifier les
choses dans cette course aux jobs
yvelines information jeunesse proposait
un forum cet après midi olivier
maniscalco patrick jacques de dixmude
étaient sur place ils ont constaté non
seulement le succès de l'opération mais
aussi la forte demande pour faire un
petit boulot à l'étranger
comme etienne qui écoutent avec
attention les conseils d'olivier ils
étaient déjà près de 300 étudiants à la
mi journée ce mercredi à la mairie de
versailles pour le forum job d'été un
forum qui permet aux jeunes de
rencontrer directement les employeurs ou
d'être aidés pour la rédaction des cv et
lettres de motivation
une tâche pas toujours évident au
premier abord surtout sur le stand de
jobs à l'étranger particulièrement
plébiscités mais pour être embauché dans
un autre pays il faut forcément
s'adapter les anglais ont des règles qui
sont inverses en français c'est à dire
le cd peut être sur plusieurs pages mais
la lettre de motivation sur une seule
page et donc ça c'est toujours un petit
point détails sur lesquels le français
les français ne sont pas souvent au
courant et donc nous notre mission c'est
justement de les informer et de les
aider sur la rédaction et nous c'est
notamment si le tout est de corriger
tout ce qui est des petites coquilles et
compagnie ça ça arrive
les jeunes repartent avec des réponses à
leurs questions des offres d'emploi et
surtout rassurés quant à leur prétention
de départ à l'étranger l'arrivée un peu
les mains vides puis de le dire bah oui
rien qu'avec ton cv sais c'est pas mal
j'ai tu parles bien je pense que oui on
va te regarder sur différents sites et
puis y'a plus qu'à postuler et puis même
si on n'arrive pas sur les sites ils ont
besoin d'un gros livre yahia j'ai des
offres sont disponibles c'est la
coopération en france selon
l'observatoire de la vie étudiante 35%
des jeunes ont un job à côté de leurs
études
politiques à voisins le bretonneux à
l'issue des municipales pas de bascule
d'une formation à une autre mais un
changement de maire à droite alexis
piette a été battu par son ancienne
première adjointe la centriste alexandra
rosetti vient de rentrer en fonction ce
week end mais pour le maire sortant des
irrégularités viennent entacher le
scrutin
après le verdict des urnes place au vote
des élus afin de désigner officiellement
le nouveau maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux son suspense
alexandra rosetti prend la tête de la
commune pour les six prochaines heures
battus lors du scrutin le maire sortant
alexis millette devrait déposer un
recours et demandé l'annulation du vote
15 voix séparent sa liste de celles
menées par son ancienne adjointe et
après une campagne difficile les
rapports entre les deux élus restent
tendues malheureusement nous constatons
un certain nombre d'irrégularités
ce qui pose un cas de conscience pour
nous de savoir si nous pouvons le
laisser faire une équipe qui a agi de
telle façon frauduleuse madame rose et
il ne m'a pas contacté depuis l'élection
de dimanche c'est je trouve ça dommage
mais je suis à sa disposition à
disposition de l'équipe qui est c'est
vrai inexpérimentés et donc pour
transmettre les dossiers et donné je
pense des conseils il n'y a pas eu
d'irrégularités du tout je suis
parfaitement sereine sur ce sujet là
donc voila nous verrons nous verrons
bien ce qui se passe pour l'instant j'ai
pas eu de vendre un recours officiel
représentants de la majorité de
l'opposition se retrouveront également à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines où ils siègeront en revanche
dans le même camp celui du centre et de
la droite face à une gauche dorénavant
minoritaires
et l'installation de cette nouvelle
communauté d'agglomération ce sera le 26
avril un samedi dans la matinée nous
aurons bien évidemment l'occasion d'y
revenir michel laugier le maire de
montigny le bretonneux sera candidat il
devrait sauf surprise prendre la tête
donc de cette agglomération à la suite
du socialiste robert cadalbert
l'association nationale médias handicap
basée à montigny le bretonneux qui fête
ses dix ans son fondateur sébastien
incroyable est l'invité de ce journal
bonsoir et bienvenue en plateau vous
êtes s'accompagner d'une natte de vaud
adhérentes virginie bertrand bonsoir
vous êtes venu avec votre fille vont
faire toi adeline tu es membre aussi est
très active dans cette association
médias handicap on va en parler dans un
instant cette association qui s'est
fixée pour but de promouvoir l image des
personnes handicapées dans les médias de
favoriser également leur accès aux
métiers de la communication et de la
culture quel est le constat aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il est compliqué pour une
personne en situation de handicap de
devenir par exemple un professionnel des
mets ou d'avoir accès aux médias c'était
déjà bien vous employez bien le terme de
personnes en situation de handicap tant
qu en terme d'image on a déjà avancé et
nous faisons des actions depuis dix ans
des actions de sensibilisation à
montigny le bretonneux ou à paris et
remis en situation de handicap des
personnes valides pour montrer
l'accessibilité dans les lieux publics
est aussi au fait t'es ses interviews
avec des personnalités dont harry
roselmack qui est notre parrain officiel
2010 qui a impliqué on le voit sur les
images que vous avez réalisés lors de
cette journée d'anniversaire à chaque
année vous réalisez les parrains les
membres de l'association assure paris on
voit quelques images qui ont été
tournées harry roselmack était une fois
de plus présent virginie bertrand vous
votre engagement au côté de celle de
sébastien paillard remonta à caen et
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé un petit peu
ça fait trois ans et nous c'est au sein
de la famille toute la famille est
impliquée comme mon mari même mon fils
de 8 ans
on a connu sébastien lors d'une
de la semaine du handicap avec les
écoles de montigny-le-bretonneux et on
est venu justement cet anniversaire
un dimanche pour voir un petit peu
comment ça se passait exactement puisque
les écoles de montigny quand même 3 et
sensibiliser sur le handicap et c'est là
qu'on ait connu sébastien et adeline a
adhéré tout de suite il a voulu
s'investir beaucoup plus dans
l'association et on a poussé nos enfants
à faire cette démarche alors comment tu
t'investis justement toi moi lors de la
semaine du handicap
j'installe les défis ged a préparé puis
j'en parle autour de moi qu'est ce que
tu penses de son de ce combat justement
pour les pour les personnes en situation
de handicap pour l'accès aux aux médias
qu'elle regarde toi tu as surtout ça m'a
choqué c'est bien ça puisse
choquer c'est bien c'est un beau combat
oui ce combat lorsque vous voyez
justement des gens qui viennent vous
rejoindre qui veulent en savoir plus
qu'ils s'impliquent comme ça c'est aussi
une satisfaction après 10 ans est un
faucon pas et c'est aussi de la jeunesse
peut-être que tu en quelques années elle
va me remplacer donc
elle est très dynamique et elle parle
bien aussi elle a fait un exposé dans
cinq collèges donc c'est très important
aussi de sensibiliser les plus jeunes
sur cette thématique là et on le constat
là actuellement c'est qu'on avance à peu
tout doucement mais il ya encore des
barrières à franchir et au niveau des
médias ce serait bien que tu en dix ans
on a une bonne représentativité à des
personnes en situation de handicap dans
les médias mais pas simplement le
fauteuil roulant parce que l'eau photo
roland c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt
il ya aussi personnes notre cardiaque
les personnes épileptiques les personnes
à un problème cardiaque donc faut pas
simplement de mettre de la visibilité
tiens un fauteuil roulant une personne
qui a amputé et voilà on avec les
problèmes de la visibilité je crois que
c'est ça sébastien vous êtes surnommé
l'homme un défi vous êtes atteint vous
même un d'une maladie neuromusculaire
vous avez relevé des challengers
impressionnant record en natation
parachutisme en tandem vole également
avec la patrouille de france bat sait si
j'en oublie même mais aussi je me trompe
nager avec des dauphins mexique aussi
formule 3000 volts ans à un fouga
magister
c'est un ancien avion patrouille de
france et le tenait à coeur santé une 4
c'était pour lancer l'association s'est
elle a traversé une partie de la scène
en pleine mode kayak avec le commentant
à la roue qui aussi sont aussi visés un
temps l'association etc a animé la
soirée anniversaire des dix ans j'avais
harry roselmack m.sow la maxime taurine
base est aussi aussi plus important des
personnes handicapées qui s'investissent
avec le soutien des adhérents et des
bénévoles très actifs comme adeline et
virgin on avait quelques images de vos
précédents défi au sein de votre travail
également vous avez mis en place à un
portail intranet pour sensibiliser les
salariés aussi à cette question du
handicap juste pour revenir sur toute
cette motivation quel est le l'objectif
pour vous c'était de montrer que l'on
peut parler des personnes handicapées
mais différemment et qu'il fallait pour
cela aussi que ce soit elle les
premières qui s'impliquait et qui montre
une autre facette je pense qu'on peut
parler des personnes handicapées mais
pas les stigmatiser il faut parler des
personnes handicapées avec en leur
lançant des défis à réaliser avec des
personnes valides ou des bénévoles et
avec la complicité des personnalités et
par le pied tu étais si on envoie une
image positive de la personne handicapée
temps genia après si les médias ne nous
répondent pas je contacte est comme et
ya quelques mois pour faire un reportage
si nous contacter ou pas c'est leur
problème mais nous on a fait déjà la de
la démarche et je tiens à souligner
aussi le soutien de téléfilm depuis pas
mal de nombreuses années qui me connaît
et et rossi de téléphiles 118 ainsi que
d'amis rue de montigny proto mieux
le ccas est aussi à monsieur le maire
michel loger et une forte implication
seront continuées à chaque année avec
cette semaine du handicap à laquelle
vous participez on va juste écouter un
micro trottoir à présent nous sommes
allez vous rencontrer dans les rues de
saint quentin en yvelines avec cette
question est quelle image véhiculent les
médias des personnes en situation de
handicap selon vous y at il encore du
chemin à parcourir vos réponses ils ont
peut-être pas passé par contre il on
parle pas trop
c'est sûr que c'est pas trés pas très
explicite au niveau des dans les médias
je sais qu'il est handicapé quant aux
mesures qui sont dans le besoin mais
personne véhicules l'information pour
les handicapés de beaucoup qui sont
hypocrites ils parlent on fait ça pour
les handicapés machin et tout mais ce
n'est pas le cas pour moi aucune ouais
je trouve qu'ils sont pas forcément
assez représentés au niveau des médias
où on n'en parle pas assez en tout cas
je pense qu'on pourrait faire de plus
des missions avec des handicapés que ce
soit des candidats ou des animateurs
télé ou même des journalistes quand le
téléthon va dire sinon en dehors de ça
je n'entend pas beaucoup parler d'eux et
encore du travail visiblement les clans
et les gens sont demandeurs ils
trouveraient ça normal il faut que les
médias aussi arrête d'être sourd est il
qu'ils voulaient aussi dans un temps des
établissements qui sont sclérosées aussi
donc l évolution fait va se faire tout
doucement mais donc nous on fait notre
démarche surtout les contacts et après
s'ils ne répondent pas on devra insister
avec l'appui maintenant d'un parrain
officiel qui est harry roselmack
peut-être qu'on va avoir plus de
facilité mais en face on le handicap
c'est un combat au quotidien donc ne
jamais baisser les bras sort pour
refaire les lacets on retire ya pas de
démotivation des bénévoles aussi
quelquefois de vous dire que les choses
n'avancent finalement pas assez vite non
parce que comme vous avez des enfants
qui sont dans un fauteuil et qui ont la
chance de jouer avec des enfants valides
c'est une grande satisfaction parce que
vous avez un grand sourire d'enfant en
fauteuil qui justement n'ont pas
l'habitude de jouer avec des enfants
valides et là vous voyez qu'à une
barrière qui tombe ça c'est plus que
c'est le plus beau cadeau vous ayez que
tu parlais tout à l'heure de ton
engagement et de ce que tu peux tu sais
ce que faisait notamment dans ton
établissement scolaire quand tu en
parles autour de toi tes copains et
copines
jusqu'au moment ils comprennent cette
application ce combat quelles sont les
questions qui se posent bien souvent on
pose pourquoi tu as fait ce choix d'un
mois je leur explique que j'aime bien
aider et m'investir dans des projets qui
me tiennent à coeur donc moi j'ai donc
envie templiers encore longtemps dans
l'association est remplacé sébastien un
jour qu'ils voient ce qui était pour sa
place de président et de vice présidente
mais est ce qui est important aussi
c'est c'est l'engagement des pouvoirs
publics sur ce sujet là
c'est bien de faire des lois après il
faut mettre en place et le tp après il
faut faire des actions ça commence à se
mettre en place tout doucement mais
c'est tout en douceur donc faut aller
moins vite mais faire des bonnes actions
et - habitants la communication retient
ya eu des lois autour du handicap pour
ne serait-ce que l'accessibilité aux
lieux publics des lois qui ont été mis
un petit peu entre parenthèses parce que
ça coûte forcément très cher et avec la
crise ça donnait effectivement un bon un
bon argument pour mettre de côté tous
les aménagements qui sont prévues au
delà de ça vous avez le sens même le
sentiment d'être d'être oublié parfois
qu'on parle des handicaps justement
quelques choix pour se donner bonne
conscience et puis dès qu'il ya des
réalités économiques qui arrivent ça y
est on oublie aujourd'hui vous avez
l'impression d'être que les personnes en
situation de handicap sont une priorité
aussi pour le gouvernement on en parle
beaucoup moins je pense que la priorité
elle reste mais elle est peut-être moins
visible et il cirait que le gouvernement
il torée à
travailler plus sur cette thématique là
et comme là il ya aussi un changement de
premier ministre faux attentats parce
que la secrétaire d'état aux personnes
handicapées c'est une nouvelle aussi
donc faut attendre qu'il arrive quoi
qu'il arrive et il ya beaucoup de
travail mais il faut jamais baisser les
bras et moi je fais mes sacs sont au
niveau de saint quentin en yvelines de
paris avec des bénévoles actifs et elle
seule plus important aussi c'est bien de
se lancer des défis en tort une
association se tient comme la gelée
faire tu théâtre le 21 et 22 avril c'est
à la salle de la tour à voisins le
bretonneux et
je suis avec une équipe de théâtre très
dynamique la compagnie une carte de fou
entre le dirigeant et victor et clément
le bateau et je fais je me relève je
relève des défis avec eux et avec la
troupe pour présenter un spectacle le 21
et le 22 avril à la salle de la tour
s'écrasant prochain défi mais parce que
il ya un handicap qu'il soit pas
beaucoup c'est un handicap non visible
j'ai souffert de bégaiement je suis qu'à
l'âge de 25 ans donc c'est j'aime bien
le tueur scène parce que je m'épanouis
par rapport à ça pour caro s'il est un
handicap non visible qui sont importants
c'est 80% de la population donc c'est
très important s'il ne pas simplement
mettre un fauteuil roulant il ya une
personne amputé des quatre membres et
bien voilà on a tout fait dans le
domaine du handicap non il ya beaucoup
de travail il ya aussi les syndicats non
visibles s'étaient montés sur scène
d'ailleurs juste une parenthèse avec
edouard baer il ya quelques années sur
la seine à paris à ses côtés pour un
pour un petit sketch justement pour
montrer que vous pouviez y arriver
malgré ce sommet du monde qu'on ait
réussi à vaincre on parler de vos défis
le prochain défi pour l'association ce
sera quoi qu'elle est sur quoi va porter
le travail pour les dix prochaines
années
alors on en train de regarder justement
pour
faciliter certains certains projets par
exemple des promenades avec des enfants
même des personnes de plus de plus plus
âgés qui sont bloqués par exemple sur
certains projets parce que facilement on
dit ça vas-y on peut le faire oui mais
quand vous faisiez dans un fauteuil vous
vous rendez compte que bah enfin quand
on peut pas donc on est en train
d'étudier plein de choses pour voir
comment on peut s'organiser pour
justement
mais non j'ai valides et invalides pour
pouvoir organiser différents projets
comme des balades comme organiser des
petites sorties sur les allées voir les
animaux et autres mais c'est vrai que
c'est des choses qui vont être plus ou
moins faciles à mettre en place parce
qu'il faut quand même qu'on étudie
toutes les questions de sécurité qu'on
étudie la faisabilité du projet en
fonction de certains fauteuils vous
pouvez faire certaines choses que vous
pouvez pas avec d'autres il ya tout une
question de sécurité ou autre et là
c'est vrai que c'est un projet qui nous
tient à tous tout le monde de
l'association à coeur et qui va falloir
qu'on travaille à qui n'ont dessus avec
sébastien ça nous tient à coeur parce
que toute personne handicapée que
virginie est allé rencontrer avec
adeline est aussi jamie qu'elle 1 qu'est
ce que vous avez envie de sortir voilà
personne handicapée elle veut sortir
déjà parce que quelques toiles et un
centre-tir éducation et l ce à quoi vous
donc elle veut sortir elle peut
connaître des personnes des personnes
valides donc c'est important c'est un
projet qui sera financé au simple
association on va étudier la faisabilité
comme virginie est aussi a aussi la
célèbre semaine du handicap qui a lieu
du 6 au 12 octobre 2014 et nous offrait
la 7e édition du triathlon de
l'espérance ces trois défis en situation
de handicap sur cette semaine sur le
bleu pour le mot de la fin sera pour toi
forcément qu'il y travaille déjà pour
cette semaine du handicap tu disais y
être impliqué
oui j'essaye d'être là mais
j'essaye d'en parler autour de moi n'est
ça
avec eux des prospectus des exposés des
gens toujours faire connaître le travail
de média handicap merci à tous les trois
sébastien bravo aux bénévoles également
qu'ils s'engagent pour ses dix ans donc
2010 handicap merci encore
nous poursuivons ce journal avec l'
agence de biomédecine qui organise sa
neuvième semaine de mobilisation en
faveur du don de moelle osseuse et ce
jusqu'au 12 avril priorité augmenter
sensiblement le nombre de donneurs ce
qu'ils deviendront ensuite des veilleurs
de vie c'est le terme consacré 2400
nouveaux donneurs sont nécessaires en
ile de france rebecca 8000 jeunes
yvelinoise a été greffé il ya bientôt
dix ans elle témoigne de son parcours au
micro de yolaine torres
rebecca rubis va bientôt fêter ses dix
ans de greffe en pleine semaine de
mobilisation pour le don de moelle
osseuse cette jeune femme est un bel
exemple d'espoir face à la maladie
touché par un premier cancer à l'âge de
21 ans elle est ensuite atteinte d'une
leucémie aiguë à l'âge de 25 ans si elle
en est aujourd'hui guéri c'est grâce au
don de moelle osseuse d'un donneur
allemand moi je l'appelle mon frère de
faim puisque je suis sa copie minutes à
faire que j'ai changé le groupe sanguin
je suis né à plus et je suis devenu au
plus tout comme mon donneur un donneur
au départ compatible à 80 % uniquement
les médecins la 10è condamnés ils ont
tenté le tout pour le tout et la greffe
a fonctionné un de ses rêves aujourd'hui
pouvoir rencontrer son donneur et le
remercier elle lui a déjà écrit
plusieurs fois via l' agence de
biomédecine
la première fois c'était pour sa
première année de guérison au bout de
cinq ans je verrai créé une nouvelle
lettre et là j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
un grand bonheur c'est à dire que
quelques jours avant mon anniversaire
mon médecin greffeur avec qui j'avais
une consultation m'a tendu une lettre m
a dit on de north a répondu et là on
était tout seul dans son bureau en
larmes parce que voilà c'était juste
extraordinaire et il me considère comme
sa soeur devant et tout comme lui enfin
on pense tous les jours l'un à l'autre
aujourd'hui rebecca à des examens de
sang tous les six mois pour vérifier
qu'elle est en bonne santé juriste
comédienne professionnelle
saxophoniste ou encore aux membres de
l'association laurette fugain elle ne
s'arrête jamais et profite pleinement de
ce qu'elle appelle sa deuxième vie le 30
septembre prochain je vais fêter mes
différents de greffe donc c'est juste
une chance extraordinaire et et ça m'a
permis de voilà de réaliser tout tout
tout plein de projets et pouvoir revivre
me dire que j'avais une deuxième vie
vous fait véritablement comme un enfant
qui vient de naître ça veut dire que
vous n'avez plus de mémoire immunitaire
tout a disparu est fait pour ça qu'on
est extrêmement fragile c'est pour ça
que à l'issue de la greffe on sort dans
la rue avec un masque pour se protéger
de l'extérieur puisque la moindre petite
bactérie peut être dangereuse pour un
malade qui vient de recevoir une greffe
elle raconte son combat dans un livre
qu'elle aimerait voir publier pour se
disent on greffe un livre qui parle
avant tout de son message d'espoir la
médecine n'est pas une science exacte
les médecins ont des pronostics bien
évidemment ils sont là pour vous dire
mais je savais que je devais mourir mais
je me suis battu j'ai cru en la vie et
pour moi je me fais toujours dit que je
serai plus forte que mes deux camps
faire que j'ai eu voilà donc j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir ben je sais pas plein de
plein de vie puisque aussi je suis le
fruit de deux pleins de donneurs qui
vont du nez du centre des plaquettes
pour continuer mes traitements mais
surtout je suis là grâce à un donneur de
moelle osseuse pour cette neuvième
semaine de mobilisation pour le don de
moelle osseuse l' agence de biomédecine
cherche à recruter 18 mille nouveaux
donneurs d'ici 2015 l'objectif est de
taille diversifier les profils
génétiques pour augmenter les chances
des malades lorsqu'on sait qu'ils ont
une chance sur un million de trouver un
donneur compatible
à savoir que pour être donneur il suffit
d'avoir entre 18 et 50 ans et d'être en
bonne santé comme rebecca il ya quelques
années plus de 2000 personnes atteintes
d'une maladie grave du sang ont
aujourd'hui besoin d'une greffe en
france
et
culture chaque année la ville de
versailles propose son rendez vous dédié
à la bande dessinée après 13 l'an
dernier jusqu'au 4 mai et présenter une
rétrospective est des 20 ans de la
collection signée des éditions le
lombard à travers plus de 100 dessins
originaux aurélia domicile et jonathan
vilma
rendez vous annuel des amateurs et
collectionneurs de bandes dessinées pour
sa sixième édition l'exposition bd de
versailles met à l'honneur jusqu'au 4
mai n'ont pas un auteur mais toute une
collection et il s'agit de la collection
signée des éditions le lombard qui
célèbrent cette année leur vingtième
anniversaire elle compte aujourd'hui une
trentaine d'auteurs confirmés et
reconnus dans le paysage du 9e art
l'exposition présente l'ensemble des
romans graphiques issues de la
collection à travers plus de 100 origine
cette exposition est particulière parce
que on montre la diversité des dessins
du fait qu'il ya un grand nombre de
dessinateurs il ya plus de 20 de plus de
20 dessinateur et plus d'une centaine de
planches originales et on y retrouve
donc à un grand nombre de dessins et
puis surtout les palettes graphiques
vraiment différente de ses auteurs on
retrouve des pâtes complètement
différente certains qui dessine en
couleur directe de ti son encan
classique de qui sont en l'avis de qui
son crayonné il ya vraiment une
diversité du dessin et qui fait la
richesse de cette collection loin des
albums en serre et la collection signée
a la particularité de donner carte
blanche aux auteurs pour raconter une
histoire en un ou deux volumes c'est
vraiment comme si on faisait un truc
ultra personnel senges physique suivie
par
par une contrainte soit éditorial soit
commerciale ici on n'avait pas quoi
c'est super important des expos comme ça
parce qu'on rencontre des gens on
rencontre des gens qui ont lu notre
bouquin parce qu'il faut savoir que
c'est un métier quand même un métier de
solitaire on travaille un peu on
travaille pendant des mois seul dans une
pièce à pondre un scénario à se mettre
en image et tout donc on en vient
presque à la fin du bouquin on en vient
presque à sociaux quoi les dessinateurs
de bd ici ça nous pousse un peu à
rencontrer les gens à leur demander
pourquoi tient coi pourquoi là tu prix
en rayon pourquoi là tout est ouvert
pourquoi tombe bien qu'elle sait pas
plus est ce que le rythme te plaît donc
c'est super important pour moi un grand
nombre de dessinateurs seront présents
les prochains week-ends pour des
dédicaces notez également qu'un tirage
spécial et proposer des deux best seller
de la collection bouche du diable de
bouquets charyn et mezek de julia ryan
en édition limitée à 350 exemplaires
tirés uniquement pour l'exposition
pour un point complet sur l'actualité
culturelle du moment à saint quentin en
yvelines et aux alentours rendez vous
avec aurélia de bissy ce mercredi soir
sur tv fils 18h30 19h30 et 1 23 heures
je vous retrouve pour ma part demain
pour une nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'acte
une très bonne soirée
m